foreign
[Music]
driving along
Dragon life
stop stop
Gary what's up court order for acid
seizure you got to pay your property
taxes Maddie no this is a mistake I'm
negotiating a payment schedule with them
hello I guess they're done negotiating
what so they're taking my car I'm an
Uber driver my problems how the am
I supposed to pay their taxes just
bartending my problem is that you just
won radio silent on me
is that what this is about no I also
have a contract with the county but I'm
saying a little explanation about why I
never heard from you again that would
have been nice you can't just ghost
people three months is not nothing it's
three months felt longer
in a good way
you were right okay my feelings for you
were so intense that I got scared and
freaked out
is that true yes of course it's true you
big dummy
last night I was doing laundry and I
thought to myself
I missed that
I miss hearing about what the Jets were
doing wrong what you would do
differently if you ran the team yeah
that'd be so much better right it'd be
so much better
the other day I saw a green sock and I
was like that's Gary's
this feels good
say my car wasn't here okay
yeah
you know what I will do that
because it's not going to be here
what
that's my cousin
he's from Italy Gary I swear to God he's
my cousin he's my second cousin that's
their culture have you ever been to
Italy I wanted closer and I got closer
thank you Gary Come on it was just a
flame no no I wasn't not to me
my sister was right about you
wait your sister who was arrested for
elder abuse
hey Gary
there's something seriously wrong with
you
what you think you're so perfect you're
indecisive which is annoying
okay Gary I'm sorry will you drop me off
I'm bartending at the claw today
God you know
I just can't decide
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
hi Gary what can I get you let me get a
banana bread
actually wait hold on
yeah I gotta go lemon loaf
I'm gonna
heated
um
it's gonna be 450.
right
um
[Music]
thank you
what the hell are you doing trying to
save my house Gary
no no no no no no no
there
[Music]
is
you got to get it together Maddie one
more infraction you lose your license a
lot of good license is gonna do and I
don't have a car my mom left me that
house it's paid off can they do this
if you haven't paid your taxes they can
so these rich move in and then our taxes
triple
the good news is you have until
September 1st
you're paid off
not without a car man
if you have any idea how much money I
lose every day I'm not ubering Summer's
when I make my nut for the year I get it
these people
are moving in trying to push me out do
you have any idea what that feels like
of course you do
thanks
see on the water all right
[Music]
yeah the new house is right on the water
I just throw it on the old place gotta
come out g t with lime
you gotta take them out on the boat like
every day
we're not open until noon
you know what bro let me call you right
back
um it is new
it's 11 57.
got it
now what time is it
it's 11 56.
why don't you go wait on your boat and
I'll blow the fog horn when we're open
what's wrong with you just ask for a
drink
what is going on here
sir I will make your drink for you good
Lord oh you know what's that you need to
fire her I can't fire her she has a
disability what no I don't you don't no
that's the reason why I hired you
know what we cannot start off the summer
like this okay you could be in any other
month of the year be in October beach in
March don't be in June okay because
these people keep our lights on these
people are the reason I'm losing my
house
I'm sorry Fern I'm just having a really
good morning yeah I see that
you know what helps me
folding napkins
oh this car is only a thousand dollars
oh no that's just the tires you're not
going to find anything on Craigslist
I've looked everywhere you could always
sell your kidney
you could sell your hair your plasma
your eggs human body's a cash cow people
don't understand that Jim I can feel our
baby getting Dumber
I'm just trying to help you could always
rent the house out no can't I can't
stand the thought of those summer people
being in my house oh hey hey look at
this
need a car for college stay at our 19
year old son this summer he's a
wonderful young man extremely smart but
socially very shy he's never had a
girlfriend and we've tried everything
we're looking for an attractive kind and
intelligent woman early in the mid-20s
to date him and bring him out of his
shell before he leaves for college in
the fall in exchange will give you a
Buick Regal clean rust free 40K miles
serious inquiries only
date is in quotes
it's got to be a joke right no
now have you seen these helicopter
parents and they'll do everything for
their kids I'm surprised they're not
gonna come themselves it does
it's a 20s though that's okay I can pass
for that
okay